after the awkward humor and the angry
speeches about donald trump joe biden
finally emerges from his basement
and he's alive i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
today's ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity should
not be public
protect yourself at expressvpn.com slash
we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first let's talk about the
fact you're probably spending way too
much on your cell phone bill now is not
a good time to be spending
too much money in fact never is a great
time to be spending too much money you
really should be looking to cut that
cell phone bill
especially if you are wasting lots of
money on unlimited data that you are not
using
that is why you should be taking a look
right now at puretalk who is your
wireless provider att verizon
t-mobile what if i told you the pure
talk usa uses the exact same network as
one of those carriers same tower same
coverage
but literally cost you half the price
how do they make it so affordable well
there are no retail stores so low
overhead you're not funding their
billion dollar ad campaigns you're only
paying for the data you need
no contract no excessive fees you'll
enjoy a limited talk text two gigs of
data all for just 20
a month that is correct the average
person is saving 400 bucks a year on
their wireless bill by moving over to
puretalk so
grab that mobile phone dial pound 250
and say ben
shapiro when you do you get this amazing
deal and you save 50
off your very first month again that is
pound 2 5 0
say keyword ben shapiro that's pound 250
say ben shapiro and you get this amazing
deal
save 50 off your first month of pure
talk and start cutting down those cell
phone bills you're spending money where
you don't need to
again dial pound two five zero and say
keyword ben shapiro
to get started alrighty so last night
the big news is that joe biden is indeed
alive he looks much more alive last
night than he has the entire campaign
now before everybody gets too excited
let's just remember that when hillary
clinton in 2016 spoke the media were all
over it they were slobbering all over
her speech it was incredible it was
historic
and then she collapsed into a van and
that was pretty much the end of her
campaign
joe biden is always one gaffe away from
his campaign's extinction
so the expectations had been set pretty
low right i mean if he if he did not
stumble
through the entire speech and or
physically fall down then this was a
victory for joe biden and he surpassed
that with these i mean he really did
i thought he looked significantly more
lively than he has any time during the
campaign
i know he's having a super beats or what
but the bottom line is that
joe biden looked as though he had some
energy for the first time in the
campaign
he's been i mean the sleepy joe moniker
that trump hung on him
early on in this in this race really did
apply it did not apply last night
biden looked much more alive he looks
much more with it his speech was
quite well written it was a very good
night for joe biden it was
it also highlighted the fact that really
the democrats have
but one play in this playbook and the
playbook is donald trump
is a bad orange man who is bad in orange
that is the entire playbook and that
makes sense
if you look at the at the pew polls from
the last couple of weeks what you will
see
is that 56 percent of people who support
joe biden say they support joe biden
because they don't like trump
it is not that people love joe biden
it's that they don't hate joe biden
right and so the bar for biden is
actually fairly low he has to be
somewhat coherent
he has to be an alive person who can
breathe on his own he has to
be not donald trump all of those things
he is capable of doing
and last night that's what he showed now
the burden for trump and the rnc
is going to be to reshift the
conversation away from trump's character
because trump is trump and his character
is going to continue to be his character
they're gonna have to reshift the
conversation away from trump
and back toward policy and that's always
kind of a hard shift because the fact is
that donald trump had an easy out in
2016. the easy out in 2016 was
yeah you think i'm terrible look at that
lady hillary clinton was wildly
unpopular for decades
it was the two most unpopular candidates
in american history going up against
each other
one of them had governed and was
unpopular one of them had not governed
and was unpopular
and americans were like okay let's try
the one who hasn't done this yet maybe
he'll be better
but biden is not sort of the same thing
it's not that biden is competent
it's not it's not that biden is
consistent on policy he isn't it's not
that biden is an important historical
figure
he is not for any particular reason it
is that biden is not
as inherently unlikable as hillary
clinton and so the avenue of attacking
joe biden on character grounds
is simply not as available as it was for
hillary clinton with regard to
donald trump and that is why the
democrats keep mining this vein
because they know that trump is going to
keep giving them material on twitter
he's going to go out he's going to make
dumb comments from now until the
election they're counting on it
the the one thing that trump could do to
stop all of this is simply to cut off
the supply
right if suddenly the democrats were cut
off
from their heroin supply of trump gaffes
and
trump nastiness on twitter they would
wither so would the media the media
wouldn't know what to do
if trump simply shut down his twitter
account for three months before the
election
he would rise in the poll by five
percent and this thing would tighten up
there are state polls showing the things
already tightening but democrats are
counting on him
not doing that you can see that the
entire democratic party is based around
this
because internally there are significant
differences right joe biden
and bernie sanders agree on very few
things
on a personal level kamala harris and
joe biden don't agree on many things in
terms of what ought to be done
policy wise the squad does not like
nancy pelosi nancy pelosi does not
particularly like the squad they are all
united by the glue of orange man bad
and so you can go through eight long
hours of dnc primetime programming
and receive zero references to the
threat of china because it doesn't
matter
the democrats have widely variant views
on what ought to be done about china
some want to be a little bit more harsh
many of them want to be a lot more
conciliatory the democrats
are fairly united in their unwillingness
to
crack down on the iranian attempted
nuclear regime in fact
they gave it a green light back during
the obama administration and so he went
eight long hours without any mention
of the greatest threat to middle east
peace namely the iranian regime
went eight long hours without any
mention at all
zero mention of rioting and looting in
america's major cities which continued
last night in portland
it means zero mention of it we've had
riots in chicago in l.a
in new york in washington d.c in
portland in seattle in seattle they set
up their own little republic and shop
people
and none of that existed if you watch
the dnc it's an alternative reality
and this is one of the problems with the
media is that the media have obscured
the actual reality in favor of an
alternative reality where all the bad
things are really about trump personally
as opposed to bad things happening
mainly in major democratic areas we went
through eight long hours of democratic
programming
without once mentioning economic
lockdowns not one which is an incredible
feat
because their main pitch on kovit is
look at the economy look how bad the
economy is
why do you think the economy's so bad it
is not purely because of the effects of
covet itself
in the early going when states were
being absolutely ravaged by covid
it was easy to make the case that it was
not government policy that was leading
to the economic failures in major states
like new york and new jersey i mean when
the virus was running roughshod through
new york and new jersey and killing
virtually everybody in nursing homes
it was at least easy to make the case
people ain't going to go out and they're
not going to circulate they're not going
to go back to the office
because they're afraid of the virus but
the fact is right now
in new york i was looking at these
numbers today in new york
there were a grand total of seven deaths
in the entire state of new york from
coveted yesterday
and they are still locked down in new
jersey
they're a grand total of nearly zero
deaths in the state of
new jersey reported yesterday which
means occurring yesterday it was
probably zero
okay they are still locked down in new
jersey they're still locked down
in major areas of the american economy
and the democrats somehow got through
eight hours of programming
in which they featured the governor of
new york they featured the governor of
california which is still shut down
and they never once mentioned that
lockdown policies may have something to
do
with the fact that the economy has
tanked
so that's pretty incredible i mean
that's obscuring all the major issues
and that is the name of the game for joe
biden right
at no point does he actually mention the
issues he just says look it's bad out
there
and i am sweetness and light that was
his entire campaign speech
last night at no point did he actually
lay forth a convincing policy
on anything his entire pitch was donald
trump is satanic
marianne williams williamson-esque
darkness forces of darkness shadowy
forces of darkness
it was a marianne williamson speech it
really was i mean that was marianne
williams and you remember back during
the primary she talked about
the forces of darkness and we will
overcome people laughed at her joe biden
just cribbed off her sheet
which is not a surprise and then he
proclaimed himself the forces of light
so that's the entire democratic campaign
which leads to two facts for the trump
campaign because
it was i think emotionally effective
again the entire campaign has now been
joe biden is empathetic he cares about
you he's a nice person he's the forces
of light and donald trump is the forces
of darkness
donald trump has got to cut off the
cocaine drug supply
to the democrats in the media of his own
gaffes and his own
personal foibles that's number one and
number two
he has to re-center on the fact that
democrats plans involve allowing cities
to be run roughshod over
by looters and rioters and allowing
economies to be locked down until the
end of time
right that is the those are the major
issues in america today and by the way
also
allowing the chinese and the iranians to
do what they will on the foreign stage
it's it's still incredible to me that
the entire media
have completely ignored the fact that
the intelligence community the same
intelligence community that is currently
finding that the russians are trying to
interfere in the election on behalf of
donald trump
also said that the chinese and iranian
governments are trying to interfere in
the election on behalf of joe biden
that's going completely without mention
and by the way china is a
much greater geopolitical threat to the
united states right now than russia
has been for for at least a decade
okay we're gonna get into the actual
events of the dnc in just one moment
first
let us talk about the fact that now is
not a great time to go to the post
office
you know what is a great thing to do is
get all the good services of the post
office directly from your home computer
this is why you need to be using
stamps.com as everybody adjusts to the
new normal we need to be smart about how
we do business stamps.com is there to
make it easier
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com in
recent months
i'm surprised it took them that long we
at the daily wire have been using
stamps.com since 2017.
it allows us to get special deals on
postage we can do everything directly
from our office
and then the packages get picked up and
we're good to go stamps.com brings all
the mailing and shipping services you
need directly to your computer
in the comfort of your home or office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices or an online seller shipping
out products
or just you're working from home you
need to mail stuff stamps.com handles it
all with ease and you get great
discounts too
five cents off every stamp up to 62 off
usps and ups
shipping rates as well you simply use
your computer to print official us
postage
24 7 any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and digital scale no
long term commitment just go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in shapiro again
that is stamps.com
type in code shapiro to get that special
deal don't waste your time don't waste
your money
go check out stamps.com today okay so
the dnc
was basically a bunch of awkward humor
and faux unity
up until joe biden emerged from the
crypt
alive alive made animate by dr
frankenstein
they started off as always with a
celebrity a celebrity
presenter last night it was julia louis
dreyfus louis dreyfus
from seinfeld and it appeared that
virtually all of her lines were written
by the late season writers of seinfeld
right no early season
writers here i mean this is this really
bottom of the barrel kind of humor
also it is worth noting here the same
democrats will claim that republicans
engage routinely in conspiracy theories
and they'll point out that president
trump didn't denounce q anon because he
didn't know what q1 was and all of that
these same people engage in conspiracy
theories like on a regular basis openly
and regularly for eight long hours of
the dnc
all you heard is that donald trump was
trying to crush the postal service so
that the mail would not be delivered in
time for the election which is just
absolute crap i mean we spent an
earlier podcast this week on exactly
this topic like 45 minutes it's just
nonsense it is unsupportable
by anything in fact or reality
nonetheless
according to julia louis-dreyfus at the
dnc in 2016 the election was stolen
full-on stolen by i kid you not facebook
and vladimir putin and fox news none of
which is true
facebook did not steal the election for
donald trump that is sure nonsense
vladimir putin did not seal the election
for donald trump
hillary clinton not visiting wisconsin
stole the election for donald trump here
is
i mean these are just open conspiracy
theories trafficked in the light of day
in the dnc
it's pretty incredible vote
right now you can text vote to 30330 to
learn
about all of your voting options and
make the best plan for
how to vote in your community wherever
you are an easy way to remember
30330 is that's the year
donald trump will finally release his
tax returns
if we all vote there is nothing facebook
fox news and vladimir putin can do to
stop us
that's that's very funny that's it yeah
it's not a conspiracy theory at all
that facebook can facebook run by cheryl
sandberg and mark zuckerberg
conspired to make donald trump sure sure
okay but if that wasn't enough humor for
you there's a lot of humor last night
julie louis dreyfus also did a comedy
routine on mike pence's name
because you know it's it's because it's
not hard to because
it's racist to pronounce kamala harris's
name wrong
because everyone does it because it's
pronounced in an interesting way
like for for years everyone said kamala
and now everybody says kamala
but but it's racist because so because
listen let's let's
let's make fun of mike pence's name
so what did you think about kamala
harris's speech last night
it was tremendous i was so happy for her
i know me too she's fabulous i cannot
wait to see her debate our current vice
president
mika pines or uh is it paints
it's pronounced ponce i believe oh
some kind of weird foreign name yeah not
very american-sounding
yeah that's what people are saying
strongly
who thought that was funny like who
thought that was a honey
who who also i did enjoy
last night church became okay again that
was exciting so julie louis dreyfus was
talking up the fact that joe biden goes
to church
now in some cases he can't actually
receive communion because of course
he's a rabid pro-choice activist um but
but that's okay he goes to church a lot
apparently it's okay to go to church so
long as you don't actually believe
any of the prescriptions about life in
the womb here is julia
it's exciting stuff when democrats start
talking about god it doesn't get awkward
at all
just remember joe biden goes to church
so regularly that he doesn't even need
tear gas
and a bunch of federalized troops to
help him get there
when when will they there are funny
things you can say about trump why don't
they just say them
there are many funny things you like is
anybody sitting at home falling out loud
at this
i don't think so other comedians were
brought forth sarah cooper
whose entire schtick is making funny
faces while pretending to mouth lines
from president trump
suddenly she's she's a celebrity at the
dnc
because literally her entire stick is
she makes funny faces while mouthing
speeches by trump which by the way is
not as funny as just trump saying these
things
right trump i'm sorry trump is
inherently funny right shane gillis the
comedian
pointed this out back in march she's
like everybody on the left keeps saying
trump isn't funny
it's kind of funny that the president of
the united states has threatened a nuka
hurricane
but but democrats can't just leave well
enough alone so they have sarah cooper
author and comedian which is a loosely
defined comedian
from doing doing a routine at the dnc
this is this is
pretty low-rent stuff here
i've heard donald trump say some pretty
unhinged things
i've heard them over and over and over
again
but nothing is more dangerous to our
democracy than his attacks
on mail and voting during a pandemic
okay here's the truth donald trump
doesn't want
any of us to vote because he knows he
can't win fair and square
so whether you plan to vote by mail or
in person
wearing your mask it is your vote
and it's your right don't let donald
trump
take that away from you that was
hilarious i need to hear from this
random lady who makes tick-tock videos
that's that's that's some hilarity right
wait that wasn't meant to be funny okay
sorry
okay they also trotted out their
favorite governors i think maybe the
funniest thing that happened during the
entire dnc
is they had a governor's panel and i kid
you not they put stacey abrams on it
i'm not kidding you they actually had a
governor's panel and they had like
gretchen whitmer and they had they had a
variety
of democratic governors from across
america on this panel
and on this panel they had stacey abrams
who is not in fact a governor of a state
but they're just going to continue to
pretend that she is the governor of the
state so that was actually funny that
was like the
that was the most comedic moment there
are a few of these comedic moments that
popped up during the dnc
there's one moment where they had to
have people clap
for kamala harris's speech they put up a
big screen
of various split screens from zoom
people clapping and it turns out they
couldn't find enough people to clap so
they just duplicated
various little windows it looked like
hollywood squares except several of the
squares were exactly the same
so that was kind of fun there were some
comedic moments but they were
unintentional comedy we'll get to
the great governors and great senators
from around the united states
doing their little comedy bits in a
moment of unity it was very awkward
until biden took the stage honestly like
this was biden's night which is
kind of a surprise since he's been an
afterthought the entire convention we'll
get to all that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that if
you're a responsible person you really
do need to take care of your credit card
debt as soon as possible that starts to
mount
so incredibly quickly once you go into
credit card debt i mean i know people
whose lives have been ruined really
by not being able to pay off that credit
card debt and this is where lightstream
comes in
light stream offers a fixed rate credit
card consolidation loans from
5.95 apr with autopay and excellent
credit
it's this is significantly lower than
the average credit card interest rate
which can be 19
apr light stream will reward consumers
who have good credit with a great
interest rate
no fees get a loan from five grand to a
hundred thousand dollars and you can
even get money as soon as the day
you apply people love live stream
because it's helping them get out of the
debt
that they need to get out of there's a
reason that my listeners can take
advantage of this offer right now and
should
my listeners save even more with an
additional interest rate discount the
only way to get the discount go to
lightstream.com
shapiro that's l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com slash apparel lightstream.com
shapiro go check them out right now be a
responsible person get that credit card
debt under control right now for your
sake for your family's sake
subject to credit approval rate includes
0.50
percent autopay discount terms and
conditions apply officers are subject to
change without notice
visit lightstream.com shapiro for more
information again that's lightstream.com
shapiro go check them out right now and
be a responsible person with your
finances okay
so the democrats trotted out a bunch of
luminaries including gavin newsom who
spoke from a forest
in california wildfires are consuming
large parts of the state of california
in fact one of the reasons that
wildfires have been consuming large
parts of the state
is not just because it gets hot and dry
here it does get very hot and it does
get very dry in the state of california
it has literally my entire life
it is not breaking news that california
is hot and it is not because of global
warming per se
that california is is experiencing
wildfires wildfires have been a thing in
california for
literally as long as as modern human
beings have been living in california
it's been quite hot here for quite a
while
gavin newsom sat in the forest and
explained that it was global warming's
fault not his forest management
fault right he doesn't clear they don't
do any sort of forest clearing so that
leaves a lot of really really dry
terrain
for the fires to race across gavin
newsom took some time out to go to the
forest
james co what was weird is james comey
was hiding behind that big tree behind
him
and uh and then talk about global
warming meanwhile we have rolling
blackouts across the state of california
i mean this is just
this state is so unbelievably mismanaged
my state is the most beautiful state in
the union
it also happens to be the most
mismanaged state in the union it's
absolutely incredible they're talking
about raising
the tax rates again they're about
raising the top tax rate in the state of
california to nearly 17
on top of the federal rate which would
put the top tax rate around 54
in the state of california combined
state and federal they are talking about
a wealth tax that would follow you
around for 10 years after you leave the
state
there are 66 000 homeless people in la
county right now on the streets
they're rolling wildfires across the
state they are rolling blackouts in the
middle of a giant heat wave
right because people are using their
their electricity more they are shutting
off electricity to people
in the middle of a heat wave where it is
104 degrees outside in la
and here is gavin newsom taking some
time out to talk to you from the forest
about global warming really high
high priority stuff here from the
kendall of the governor that we have out
here
i'm about a mile or so away from one of
over 370
wildfires that we're battling here in
the state of california
we were just coming off a record week a
heat wave
that led to 130 degree temperatures the
highest temperature ever recorded
in california arguably the world's
history here
in our state the hots are getting hotter
the dries are
getting drier climate change is real if
you are in denial
about climate change come to california
okay climate change is indeed real in my
opinion
and in the opinion of most scientists
climate change is indeed
largely human caused according to most
scientists also all of the measures that
gavin newsom encourages with regard to
climate change will have literally zero
impact on the climate
for the next several decades so he
better get a plan together to you know
stop the wildfires and rolling blackouts
in his state dumbass
and meanwhile it wasn't just gavin
newsom being a dumbass
it was it was a wide variety of
democrats making fools of themselves
last night mayor acacia lance bottoms of
atlanta was featured
last night her city has been in a state
of of some
of pretty significant turmoil ever since
the shooting of ray shard brooks
near wendy's after rachael brooks fell
asleep in a drive-through at wendy's
and i believe is a person of color who
called the cops the cops showed up
discussed with him for 45 minutes
and then he attacked the police officers
he tried he seized a taser from one
tried to shoot one tried to shoot the
other and then got shot
that led to riots in the streets and
kisha lance bottoms talking about
cutting the cops
and a d.a trying to indict the cops and
the cops
basically sticking out doing a blue out
and kisha lance bottoms was featured at
the dnc anyway
because that's how all of this works so
here was kisha lance bottom suggesting
once again
in part of the new democratic mythology
the black people are being prevented
from voting across the united
states despite the fact that black
people routinely outvote their share of
the population in presidential elections
and have since barack obama here is
keisha lance bottoms
the baton has now been passed to each of
us
we've cried out for justice we have
gathered in our streets to demand
change and now we must pass on the gift
john lewis sacrificed to give us we must
register and we must vote
okay can i understand the drive to get
people to vote but the idea that you are
being threatened with inability to vote
in the united states today is nonsense
it's just sheer crap
okay so we got kisha lance adams we also
got senator tammy duckworth another one
of the also rans for vice president who
is not selected
so senator duckworth just did a pure
anti-trump speech
which is really the uniting glue of the
democratic party she suggested that
trump doesn't deserve to call himself
president
and she also suggested that trump is
easily manipulated by dictators
here she was going after trump joe biden
would stand up for what's right
stand tall for our troops and stand
strong
against our enemies because unlike trump
joe biden has common decency he has
common sense
he can command both from experience and
from strength
donald trump doesn't deserve to call
himself commander-in-chief for another
four minutes
let alone another four years our troops
deserve
better our country deserves better
okay my favorite part of the democratic
platform here is that it's very
difficult to say a positive thing about
joe biden other than joe biden as a nice
person
he's been a horrible legislator for
virtually all of his career his
signature legislation that was good
the criminal justice bill of 1994 he is
disowned
which means that he really has no signal
accomplishments on his record
so instead what they just do is they
contrast a fake joe biden
with donald trump and so we're going to
see tammy duckworth do that in
just one second this is part of the
program again orange man bad and by
contrast biden good although we can't
really name a good thing that joe biden
has done legislatively other than he's
kind of like a nice person that people
seem to like we'll get to that in just a
moment first
now many people may think that i am 100
brains but occasionally i like to smile
particularly with my children
and when i do i want my teeth to be
straight also we have to take lots of
photos around here i need my teeth to
look good this is why i've been using
candid
candid clear aligners are comfortable
removable totally invisible unlike wire
braces so you can transform that smile
without anyone noticing plus
your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement
candid only works with orthodontist
never general dentists like other
companies and with some of those other
companies
you may never hear from a doctor as you
go through treatment which is ridiculous
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan so
you never have to wonder how you are
doing you'll always know which is
fantastic
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then
cost an average of 50 less than
invisalign if you're ready to take the
first step toward getting your dreams
mallet you can't wait to show off get
started today from the comfort of your
own home
with candids risk-free starter kit and
75 bucks off go to candidco.com
shapiro use code shapiro that is
candidco.com
shapiro use code shapiro for that risk
free starter kit and 75
bucks off make your teeth look glorious
candid co.com
shapiro use code shapiro okay so tammy
duckworth
also again setting up this narrative
where it's not just that donald trump is
bad it's also that joe biden is good at
things now the problem is
that you can make the case for the
former very difficult to make the case
for the latter here was tammy duckworth
suggesting that joe biden will not let
himself be manipulated like a puppet by
dictators
this is eminently untrue the biden
administration would look very much like
the obama administration which was
manipulated routinely by both vladimir
putin as well as the iranian malls to
the point where the
obama administration became almost a
literal mouthpiece
for the iranian theocracy incredibly
incredible they were literally doing pr
for the iranians pretending that the
iranian regime had moderated while they
were pursuing terrorism against american
troops in iraq
here is senator tammy duckworth however
suggesting that trump is easily
manipulated while biden
he's a stalwart strong guy who will
never be manipulated except for how his
entire career is basically a story of
him being wrong on every foreign policy
issue of the modern era
they have a coward in chief who won't
stand up to vladimir putin
read his daily intelligence briefings or
even publicly admonish adversaries
for reportedly putting bounties on our
troops heads
as president joe biden would never let
tyrants manipulate him like a puppet
he would never pervert our military to
stroke his own ego
he would never turn his back on our
troops or threaten them against
americans
peacefully exercising their
constitutional rights i'm amazed to hear
strong on defense from the democrats
that is a hell of a take
the democrats have been in favor of
slashing the military for as long as i
have been alive
this notion that donald trump is a
threat to the troops
well joe biden is a friend of the troops
is a pretty incredible statement
okay so it was this sort of awkward
dance last night before they got to
biden
between weird humor weird awkward humor
like not even good parks and recreation
style awkward humor just weird awkward
humor and donald trump is a bad man so
cory booker and bernie sanders showed up
mainly so that cory booker could remind
you that he has a girlfriend
uh and he talked to bernie sanders so
here was mr potato head putting on his
happy eyes
uh and he was excitedly talking about
rosario dawson his girlfriend
liking bernie sanders and then bernie
making weird
statements and yeah it was it was it was
kind of strange
you could think of this sort of like
survivor on the out interviews of all
the people that got voted off the island
bernie bernie don't you laugh because i
got questions for you like
why does my girlfriend like you more
than she likes me
but let's be closer she wants more than
you and that's the obvious answer right
[Laughter]
oh my god oh these jokers oh i mean this
does remind you why joe biden is the
nominee right
you look at that split screen you're
like yeah probably they sure
they're probably right to take biden
yeah that is that is a picture
right there okay then pete booty judge
suddenly reminds you that there has been
massive social change in the united
states
and then my favorite part of this is
that regardless of whether you like some
of the social change that has happened
in the united states i think it is fair
to say that the united states is
significantly more tumultuous and
divided than it was ten years ago
and here's people to judge advocating
more tumult and divide by 2030
there is a long way to go but if this
much can change between 2010 and 2020
imagine what could change between now in
imagine what we could achieve this
coalition we are building
this very season gathering progressives
and moderates
independents and even what i like to
call future former republicans
standing for an america where everyone
belongs
okay so um how much further does left
want to push here
if they're saying like remember in 2010
gay marriage was still not widely
accepted in the united states and so
he's saying that same-sex marriage is
now widely accepted and that's a good
social change okay whether you believe
that or not
how much further does left want to go
here i mean it seems to me that the next
item on their agenda is simply teaching
small children that boys can be girls
and girls can be
boys well if that's where you want to be
by 2030 mind just make that explicit
just say it
out loud say that's where you want to be
so much of the democratic
platform is never saying the quiet part
out loud
and so then they brought forth a couple
more people michael bloomberg showed up
because he's pledged 60 million dollars
to the democratic party and so
he got a speaking slot even though
nobody likes michael bloomberg
now there were a couple then we got to
the actual pitch okay then we got to the
actual biden pitch so the actual biden
pitch again
once again is empathy and he's a nice
guy because that's the only pitch for
biden
and i will say that there was some
effective stuff here right so for
example this i thought was a very
effective video i thought that it was
actually quite sweet there's a 13 year
old named braden harrington
who talked about joe biden helping him
because joe biden has overcome
stuttering in his own life and braden
harrington suffers from stuttering and
so he talked about that last night i
thought this was like a great moment
right
this kind of stuff is the contrast that
democrats seek to draw it does show
where trump has a tough time right
hillary clinton is not the type of
person who takes
days out of her life to help people with
their problems joe biden
is that kind of person apparently and so
that's a good look for joe biden here
was a video that honestly was quite
affecting
without joe biden i wouldn't be talking
to you today
about a few months ago i met him in new
hampshire
he told me that we were members of the
same club
stutter it was really amazing to hear
that someone like me
became a advice
[Laughter]
president i mean that that's
good for this kid i mean really brave to
get on live tv and do that i mean
that's that's a brave thing so that was
that was really good um
the the other they brought out some kind
of normal people to talk
and most of the pics were kind of
effective like
they brought out a 95 year old former
world war ii veteran uh talking about
how he's voted republican all his life
and now he's voting for joe biden
whenever you bring up people who have
made sacrifices in the line of duty to
do this sort of thing it's very
effective here's a 95 year old world war
ii vet
making the pitch for joe biden really
more of an anti-trump pitch which again
is the entire tone and tenor here i have
been
a republican since the 1960s
i'm a member of the nra and uh
i voted for trump i think trump has
been the the worst president we've ever
had
so i'll be glad to see him go i think
joe biden will be a great leader for the
united states
like me on the day of my jump into
germany
i think joe biden cares about doing his
proper duty
for the united states and if he's
elected that's what he will do
again it's all vague but again this is
effective kind of stuff now the
democrats did make kind of a boo-boo
here they brought forth
a guy named michael from rhode island to
talk about how he was a lifelong
republican
and now he's voting for joe biden
there's only one problem michael from
rhode island is not in fact a
lifelong republican he is a an
electrical inspector
uh and uh four out of the last five
primaries he's voted as a democrat
so that that was that was kind of
awkward but aside from that that that
was the pitch
and then joe biden's kids did a little
presentation
we never hear from hunters extra
children right we never hear about his
grandchildren from
various other people um but his uh
hunter and ashley i gave a little speech
about how
joe biden is wonderful and will be there
when you need him and of course
there's no evidence that he is bad with
his children i mean apparently he is
quite good with his children
it is also true that he has been there
for hunter when he needs him i mean this
will become a campaign issue
he's been there for 100 when hunter
needs to jet set over to ukraine
and pick up a bunch of money or when
hunter needs a ride to china to close a
1.5
billion deal or whatever it was then you
know
that's that that seems like joe's been
there for him it seems like everybody
whose last name is biden has gotten rich
off the last name biden so
at that at least this much is fact check
crew
i'm hunter biden and i'm ashley biden
joe biden is our dad
and bo is our brother we want to tell
you what kind of president our dad will
be
he will be tough and honest caring
and principled he'll listen he'll be
there when you need
him he'll tell you the truth even when
you don't want to hear it
he'll never let you down he'll be rock
steady
the strongest shoulder you can ever lean
on
okay well i'm sure that hunter has
leaned on that shoulder both physically
and
uh both physically and financially many
times before again hunter is going to
emerge in this campaign
and he should emerge in this campaign
frankly because all we've heard from the
democrats is how corrupt and terrible
donald trump is believe me that stone is
not going to be left to unturned
and there are some serious questions to
be asked about how hunter biden ends up
on the
board of ukrainian gas company when he
has neither corporate experience
nor any experience with with natural gas
nor any experience in ukraine and is
picking up large scale checks so that
will come up
in the vetting i am sure okay in a
second we're gonna get to joe biden's
actual speech
because joe biden was indeed alive it
was a low bar to clear
he cleared it i thought he cleared it
pretty easily actually it turns out that
he can read live
in lively fashion from a teleprompter
and his message was sort of jarring it
was a jarring turn
from the basic message of the democrats
that we were on the verge of fascism
it was joe biden lightbringer it was
basically joe biden trying to channel
barack obama circus 2004.
right he did the whole red state blue
state thing from 2004 he did the whole
i'm going to unify the country thing
from 2008
it was very much a reversion to barack
obama's 2008 campaign
not barack obama circa 2020 where
democracy is in danger and donald trump
is a fascist and we're all going to die
it was a move towards something else i i
thought it was well it was a very smart
political speech
it didn't lay forth any policy the one
the one note i will make in critique
here
you know after all is said and done is
that the entire democratic national
convention was centered around the evils
of donald trump on a personal level if
i'm a middle-class person
living in new jersey and i can't go back
to my job because
the governor of new jersey has decided
that we're going to lock down until
kovid is completely gone forever
if i'm a person who has lost a job or
lost a family member
and i do not know how i'm going to
recover the democrats have offered no
programs for me they've offered no
program for me they've not explained
exactly what they're going to do
basically the entire pitch is that
donald trump is the font of all evil in
your life
donald trump is the is the voldemort of
the united states and if you just banish
voldemort everything will get better
immediately
that was the pitch that was made last
night i don't know how compelling that
is
it might be a little compelling because
people don't like trump but i don't know
that it's all
all fired compelling we'll get to more
of this in just one second first
if you've been listening to the show for
a while you've probably heard me talk
about my helix sleep mattress it is
excellent okay but
now helix has launched a new product
they've gone beyond the bedroom they've
started making sofas
they just launched a new company it's
called all form they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door
so what makes an all form sofa really
cool well for starters it's the easiest
way you can customize the sofa using
premium materials at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores
you can pick your fabric it is spill
stain scratch resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs
sofa size and shape to make sure it's
perfect for you and your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone
and you can always start small and buy
more seats later on if you want your
all-form sofa to grow and change with
you
when you move all form sofas are also
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping in the past if you
wanted to order a sofa it could take
weeks or months to arrive and you need
someone to come and assemble for you
assemble it for you all form takes just
three to seven days to arrive you can
assemble it yourself in a few minutes
we did it i have an old farm sofa it's
fantastic it is
super comfortable it is super durable
which is great so my kids wreck
everything
if getting a sofa without trying it in a
store sounds risky you don't have to
worry you have 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it
more than three months and then they'll
just pick it up for free if you don't
like it but you're gonna love it i
promise all form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners right
now at allform.com
again that's all form dot com slash ben
you get 20
off all orders right now it's a
fantastic deal for a fantastic sofa go
check them out right now allform.com
okay we're gonna get to joe biden's
actual speech last night in just one
second first
i want to tell you about our most
exclusive membership tier over at the
daily wire i'm talking about all access
all access members get to join all
access live that's our exclusive live
stream discussions
hosted every night by each of the hosts
including me last night we did a special
version of all access live we forced
matt walsh to host a watch party for the
final night of the dnc
better matt than me tonight we will
completely recap the dnc for you on
daily wire backstage at 7 pm eastern 4
p.m pacific
join us afterward for another all access
live where we'll discuss it all with you
in the comments and the live stream so
head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now get 20
off all access with coupon code access
that is dailywire.com
shapiro with coupon code access to get
20 off your membership
again dailybuy.com shapiro get all
access and come hang out with us
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
so the task of joe biden was to be a
trojan horse
last night and a trojan horse he was his
performance was good
right a trojan horse because people
basically suspect i think correctly
that he's probably not going to finish
out his first term and so he has to be a
trojan horse of health
he's a very very healthy vigorous man
right that that was task number one
he is also a trojan horse for the
radical left that actually runs his
party
and so he had to act like a moderate so
you heard a lot of talk about god and
the declaration of independence he heard
a lot of talk about patriotism and
american troops
and he sounded like a moderate democrat
circa 1968.
he sounds like hubert humphrey right
doesn't sound like george mcgovern he
doesn't even sound like barack obama he
sounds like hubert humphrey circle 1968.
that was joe biden's campaign last night
now he he lifted some of the
inspirational rhetoric from barack obama
back during the days where obama was
pretending to be a uniter not a divider
joe biden was out there pretending that
he was a force for light while saying
some pretty divisive and untrue things
it turns out that he said some things
that just were simply not true
so for example joe biden said that he
jumped into the race
because donald trump had said there were
very fine people
among neo-nazis and klansmen which is
not true
okay that's actually not true what
donald trump said that was wrong is
originally he said
that there were bad people on both sides
that there was
this is his original condemnation he
said there were bad people on both sides
and then people were like well why don't
you especially condemn
the kkk and the neo-nazis and he did
right he said the neo-nazis are bad
i'm not talking about the kkk i'm not
talking about the neo-nazis and then he
said
that when it came to people who were
marching that there were fine people on
both sides because he seemed to assume
bizarrely that there were people who
were marching in favor of a robert e lee
statue who were not white supremacists
so it was more of a category error than
it was
and it was not a good thing right i mean
i condemned him for it at the time but
it was not him saying that there were
good neo-nazis and good
kkks right that was not what donald
trump did
joe biden instead dumped out there this
idea that donald trump had had basically
said that neo-nazis and kkk members were
good people at charlottesville which of
course is something he did not say
just a week ago yesterday was the third
anniversary of the events in
charlottesville
close your eyes remember what you saw on
television remember seeing
those neo-nazis and klansmen and white
supremacists
coming out of fields with lighted
torches
veins bulging spewing the same same
anti-semitic bile
heard across europe in the 30s remember
what the president said when asked
he said there were quote very fine
people on both sides this isn't no it
was an overlapping for a nice guy that's
an overt lie right he didn't say that
there were very fine people among the
neo-nazis and klansmen he specifically
said that there are people who are not
neo-nazis and klan's been marching that
was not factually true
it was wrong and it provided cover for
some of the marchers but that was
again go back and listen to my podcast i
was pretty upset about it
but the characterization there is just
flatly untrue other flatly untrue things
that joe biden said
during the speech is according by the
way to the washington post is is that
joe biden claims that trump was going to
eliminate
funding for social security this is
untrue he said that he was going to
temporarily eliminate the payroll tax
okay barack obama did this he signed
into law a bill that did this in 2012
and suggested that social security would
be fully funded
the notion that that trump is defunding
social security is not true
he went after donald trump on covet
right he suggested
that that trump botched covet worse than
any place in the world that was not true
here was joe biden on covet
after all this time the president still
does not have a plan
well i do if i'm your president on day
one
will implement the national strategy
i've been laying out since
march we'll develop
and deploy rapid tests with results
available immediately
we'll make the medical supplies and
protective equipment that our country
needs
and we'll make them here in america
so basically his plan is exactly donald
trump's plan
right but he also said that donald trump
blew it and america handled it worse
than anyplace else that is flatly untrue
as the washington post even notes
so there are a few things that he said
here that were just flatly untrue but
the overall tenor of the speech again
was about how donald trump is a mean man
and
joe biden is a nice man right and that
was the pitch right empathy empathy
empathy
there's one point in here where joe
biden quoted his dad
and he does this a lot in his speeches
where he says my dad said to me joey and
then
he says something we have no idea
whether his dad actually said but he
says joey i don't care if government
solves my problems but government should
understand my problems first of all
i don't think government needs to
understand your problems unless
government has a public policy to solve
the problems
i don't look for caring or compassion
from a government agency
like if i'm looking for a shoulder to
crime i head on down to the dmv
this bizarre notion that is pushed
constantly by democrats the government
is there to care about you is really
weird
why exactly would a faceless nameless
bureaucrat i've never met care about me
i just i don't understand why you would
go seeking
care and comfort from people who you've
never met whose literal job is to
interpret
statutes and then apply them it's a very
strange thing
but anyway joe biden's entire campaign
was about empathy
so he it was about empathy and unity and
pretending he's not a radical so he
started off by saying he was going to
work hard for americans who didn't
support him which is something barack
obama once pledged to do and then
completely rejected all those people and
sick the irs on them here was joe biden
making that same pitch last night
i'm a proud democrat and i'll be proud
to carry the banner of our party into
the general election
so it's a great honor and humility i
accept this nomination
for president of the united states of
america
but while i'll be a democratic candidate
i will be an
american president i'll work hard for
those who didn't support me
as hard for them as i did for those who
did vote for me
right the unifier pitch and then he says
that he was gonna he used the word light
in the speech 11 times
that's a lot of light there's a lot of
light it was this very romantic language
about
light versus darkness again i'm the
forces of good donald trump is the force
of evil he says he's going to draw on
the best of us not the worst which is
kind of weird considering that again
eight hours of democratic national
convention programming not one iota of
condemnation
for people who are literally attempting
to burn down cities but here is joe
biden saying he's going to draw on the
best of us which
i have i have doubts let me just say
give people light those are words for
our time
the current president has cloaked
american darkness for much too long
too much anger too much fear too much
division
here and now i give you my word
if you entrust me with the presidency i
will draw on the best of us
not the worst i'll be an ally of the
light
not the darkness so he's cloaking
himself in a particular mythology about
america's recent history in which
everything was hunky-dory during the
obama days and then all time began with
the big bang of trump
that we were not divided in any way
before trump everything was fantastic
before trump
this is completely untrue i'm old enough
to remember the obama era
you probably are too if you're listening
to the show and i can easily recall
many incidents of division inside
america during barack obama's era
fostered by an administration of which
joe biden was a
key cog and component but he's saying
basically it's a back to normalcy
campaign
i've been saying by the way for
literally years i mean i told members of
the trump administration this in 2017
that the chief threat was joe biden
running a return to normalcy campaign so
i've been predicting this for quite a
while
joe biden is just fulfilling it again he
looked alive he looked more alive last
night which is good
for him right he was still slurring his
words a little bit because listen you
hit 78 you get a little bit of mush
mouth and
he still has that but he was much better
he seemed more emotionally attuned
last night and then he he made kovitz
chief pitch right i'll protect us the
way that trump didn't
again he offered no actual plan to
protect us he said he wanted a national
mass mandate which is weird because he
literally has no constitutional power as
president to do that
also he has never actually proposed a
federal program on national masking
he has simply just said that and thrown
that out there but his bottom line is
that he's going to protect you donald
trump didn't
he didn't mention trump by name i think
once in the speech but the entire speech
was really about how trump is a bad
orange man
and joe biden is a very nice man who
cares for people and will talk to ear
off on the amtrak
our current president has failed in his
most
basic duty to the nation he's failed to
protect us
he's failed to protect america and my
fellow americans
that is unforgivable as president
i'll make you a promise i'll protect
america
i will defend us from every attack seen
and unseen
always without exception every time
okay now this is a promise you cannot
keep yeah because no president can
protect you all the time from everything
right he
he's basically now putting himself in
the position of america's missile
defense system i mean that's i'm i'm
sorry but
joe biden would not have protected us
against covet how do i know because none
of the democratic governors did
nancy pelosi didn't joe biden didn't by
the way he was around
like no i mean that's that's a no on
that okay then joe biden moved on to the
racism thing and he suggested he went
back to the hopeful rhetoric of the
early obama era which is we're on the
verge of eliminating racism from america
we can we can fight racism we can remove
it there's only one problem democrats
are constantly shifting
the the definition of racism so as to
not alleviate the charges of racism it's
too valuable a
an arrow in their quiver democrats will
never let go of the charge of racism for
their political opponents so when joe
biden says we're gonna wipe
racism from america's national life he
doesn't mean that because the moment
that democrats say that racism has been
wiped from our national life which by
the way it largely has
the moment that that happened they no
longer have that as a hammer to wield
against their political opposition here
was joe biden however saying he was
going to kill racism in exactly the same
way obama said he was going to heal
racism and then proceeded to exacerbate
it
history history has thrust one more
urgent task on us will we be the
generation
that finally wipes out the stain of
racism from our national character
i believe we're up to it i believe we're
ready
uh again what does he think that we've
been trying to do for several decades at
this point
and what are his proposals for wiping
racism from our national character and
what does he even mean by racism since
we now have two
dueling definitions right one is the old
school thinking bad things about people
because of their race
which is what racism normally means then
we have the new school anti-racism which
suggests that if you don't tear down
every american system then you are in
fact a racist
joe biden doesn't mean any of that so
joe biden is his mouth is writing
checks that his body can't cash here i
mean that that is what is happening here
everybody's going to ignore that because
it was all sweetness and light
but just recognize that that speech last
night that was a cloaking device for
what the actual democratic program
is and joe biden doesn't really mean any
of that or if he does he's certainly not
going to be able to implement it
okay by to to you know carry on the
point joe biden also said that he hears
the voices of the protesters again
writers and looters don't exist in
democrat world so here was joe biden
saying here's the voice of the
protesters last night
one of the most powerful voices we hear
in the country today
is from our young people they're
speaking to the inequity and injustice
that has grown up in america
economic injustice racial injustice
environmental injustice i hear their
voices if you listen you can hear them
too
he hears voices okay well he's hearing
the voices of the protesters but again
no solution the idea is just by electing
him magically things are fixed and this
is the democratic platform
barack obama did it the other night
barack obama said
that the constitution's only value is
democracy right there are no other
values natural rights don't exist
limited government doesn't exist equal
rights before law those things don't
exist
the only value is democracy pure
majoritarian democracy it's the only
thing that matters
and he said that the protesters in the
streets should understand that if you
elect
us then the system will have worked and
you can stop protesting but if the other
side wins the system didn't work and you
should go out and you should protest
this is this is how democrats think
about government unfortunately
that the protesters are playing an
inside outside game with government if
you elect democrats then democrats will
do the work of the protesters if you
don't elect democrats then you need to
be out in the streets
shouting about things okay and then joe
biden again using this sort of subtle
contrast the subtle assumed contrast
between the glories of the obama years
and the horrors of the trump years
joe biden suggested that they won't turn
a blind eye to bounties on american
soldiers there is this
very dicey story suggesting that the
trump administration knew full well that
the russians were paying bounties to
soldiers in syria to kill amer and
afghanistan to kill americans
and that trump turned a blind eye to it
the obama administration literally sent
150 billion dollars to the iranian
government
fully acknowledging that the iranian
government would then use the money to
fund terrorism
including against american troops so you
got to take all this crap with a grain
of salt
so i take very personally and i the
profound responsibility
of serving as commander-in-chief i'll be
a president who will stand
with our allies and friends and make it
clear to our adversaries
the days of cozying up to dictators is
over
under president biden america will not
turn a blind eye to russian bounties on
the heads of american soldiers
no they'll just turn blind eye to russia
completely taking over syria and crimea
and iran funding terrorism against
american troops
they'll turn a blind eye to that okay
then
joe biden concluded with his main
message which again was light overdark i
am the forces of light donald trump is
the forces
of darkness here was joe biden
concluding last night
let us begin you and i together one
nation
under god unite our love for america
united in our love for each other
for love is more powerful than hate hope
is more powerful than fear and
light is more powerful and dark this is
our moment
this is our mission may history be able
to say
that the end of this chapter of american
darkness began here
tonight as love and hope and light
join in the battle for the soul of the
nation
this is kind of stuff right it's
marianne williamson kind of stuff but
it is more effective than biden has been
historically then
he rushed outdoors and they did this
little fireworks show so it was actually
kind of a nice american optic right
having a nominee
rush outdoors and they have this nice
little fireworks show outside the hall
where this is happening
my favorite part was not the firework
show my favorite part was the members of
the media rushing outside for it
there's some footage of members of the
media being told that it was time to go
outside for it and the reporters just
like take off like sheep
it's like a sheep dog was hurting them
outside it's really funny
if you can't see it they're literally
like sprinting outside to see fireworks
ooh
it's joe biden with they're not the
photographers guys these are not the
photograph the photographers are already
outside
none of these people have cameras this
is just the reporters who are like
trying to oh my god we gotta see
joe biden stan so we can write prose
that we obviously could have written
like five seconds later just by watching
the video hey but it was it was a
pretty sight you know good good for them
the media were gaga over this of course
chris wallace said that the biden speech
blew a big hole in trump's narrative why
because biden was
alive again the bar was very low biden
was not a corpse
he wasn't a live human and thus he blew
a big hole in trump's no the problem of
course
is that biden has to maintain this so
all it takes is joe biden collapsing
into a van once and all of this goes
away
right joe biden has to be alive every
time from here to the election it is not
enough for him to just be alive one time
at a speech reading off a teleprompter
here is chris wallace talking up joe
biden's performance
i thought it was an enormously effective
speech remember donald trump has been
talking for months about joe biden as
mentally shot a captive of the left and
yes
biden was reading from a teleprompter
and a prepared speech but i thought that
he
blew a hole a big hole in that
characterization
okay i mean i think that again the
performance was much better than biden
has been it's early and i'm old enough
to remember when people really talked up
hillary's 2016 convention speech
jake tapper said that this was the best
speech of joe biden's career
which honestly is like saying that
this is the best cardi b song it's not
saying
it's not saying a lot they're not a lot
of good joe biden speeches across the
course of his career
here here was jake tapper i've heard joe
biden give
i don't know dozens hundreds of speeches
over the years i have to say this was
one of the best
if not the best performance i've ever
seen also
kind of underlining a mistake a tactical
mistake by the trump campaign to set
expectations so low uh suggesting that
joe biden was not capable of giving a
speech like this
uh meant that he would naturally exceed
expectations
i mean i think that's true i think that
setting the expectations low is part of
the problem however
in a debate things could change fairly
radically because it's not just that joe
biden has to be able to read it's that
joe biden has to be able to move on his
feet and that one
may be a little bit of a tougher self so
what does this leave the republicans
with
well it leaves the the rnc with the task
a dual task one is refocus the american
people
on the actual things that are happening
in the united states the entire dnc was
a distraction from everything happening
in the united states other than covet
and the reason that they keep focusing
in on covid is because they've made
covet into a measmatic danger that is
out there
ready to pounce on you at a moment's
notice depending on where you are in the
country that is simply untrue
the fact is we're on a significant
downslope in florida a significant
downslope in georgia a significant
downslope in arizona
if you're in california you're still a
little bit unsafe but the fact is the
hospitals are not even close to
overwhelmed in the state of california
there is no curve in new jersey there is
no curve in new york there is no curve
in connecticut
okay so the fact is that that those
states are seeing zero deaths and close
to zero cases
and yet they are still locked down it is
up to trump to say
there are political actors out there
right now who are keeping your economy
and your schools locked down
and then proclaiming that they are
handling the virus and that is not the
way that we can handle this
one of the more striking aspects of of
biden's speech is at one point in
biden's speech he actually said there's
no miracle
that is coming for to heal covet and
biden said that in the middle of the
speech
we'll never have our lives back until we
deal with this virus
the tragedy of where we are today is it
didn't
have to be this bad just look around
it's not this bad in canada or europe or
japan
or almost anywhere else in the world
and the president keeps telling us the
virus is going to disappear
he keeps waiting for a miracle well i
have news for him
no miracle is coming there's so much
conflicting here
so much first of all it the united
states is not ranked number one
in deaths per million in fact we're not
even close to the top of the list in
terms of death per million
in the united states when he says canada
doesn't have this no canada does it's
just all in quebec
quebec actually has a death per million
rate that's closer to new york than to
the rest of the united states
if you're if you're looking at deaths
per million population across the world
we are still surpassed by belgium peru
and dora spain uk italy sweden and chile
and brazil is right on our heels and and
so is france by the way
so is mexico so is panama by the time
this is all said and done i don't think
that the united states is going to be
really close to the top of this list but
joe biden is saying that it's not true
the the main thing that he says there
though which is that there's no miracle
on the way
okay if there's no miracle on the way
then you actually have to learn to live
with the virus but you guys don't want
to learn to live with the virus you just
want to lock everything down internally
it's going to be up to trump to make
that case
and people to make that case that
democratic governors have kept this
stuff
locked they mishandled it they botched
it like cuomo did and then they kept the
thing locked down
they're gonna have to make the case also
that joe biden
is is a trojan horse for the kamala
harris left and they're gonna have to
make the affirmative case
that donald trump is likely to handle
things like the rioting and the looting
better than democrats who continue to
pat that stuff on the head
and then there's the part of the case
that donald donald trump is simply going
to have to get himself under control
if donald trump wishes to remain
president of the united states he is
going to need to shut up
he is he's going to need to stay on
teleprompter the expectations for donald
trump
are just as low as the expectations
republicans set for joe biden the
expectations that republicans said for
biden
were very simple is he alive joe biden
last night showed that he was alive and
thus surpassed expectations now tomorrow
he could kill over but
last night that was what it was the
the expectation that democrats have set
for trump is that donald trump will
never
ever stop being tumultuous and volatile
and saying ugly things on twitter and
tweeting out craziness
all donald trump has to do to surpass
that expectation is not do those things
and you'll see this happen with trump
every so often right he'll go out and
he'll give a great state of the union
address and everybody'll be like wow
that was unexpected
well no he's fully capable of that i
think that donald trump is fully capable
of putting down the phone for five
damned minutes there are plenty of other
people out there who are willing to
defend what trump is doing on a daily
basis
he can still do it in pressers but
if the entire democratic pitch is orange
man bad then it would really deprive
them of a case for orange man to be less
bad would it not
and i don't even mean in terms of policy
so the rnc's task next week
is going to be to say joe biden may be
empathetic but he ain't going to solve
any of your problems here are all the
problems in the united states and also
stay off the damned twitter that is the
task before president trump
with less than three months left until
the national election that will decide
whether he remains in office
or not okay well we have two additional
hours of content coming up for you here
on the benchmark show plus later today
we have a daily wire backstage as well
go to
dailywire.com get an all access pass
right now
coupon code access and you get 20 off
that all access passed
also pick up a copy of my brand new book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps
huge national bestseller i think it
discusses a lot of the issues that we've
been talking about routinely
go check it out right now and otherwise
we'll see here on monday so
try not to burn things down again guys
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen